regardless of what you think about
Julian Assange and what he did you
should care about what happens to him
this is part one of a series explaining
why okay who is Julian Assange in 2006
Assange founded Wikileaks which is a
website for whistleblowers where you can
anonymously upload sensitive documents
publish it to all of the world but
Wikileaks wasn't really a big deal until
2010 when Chelsea Manning who was an
Army intelligence analyst uploaded
hundreds of thousands of classified
documents exposing how the US was doing
war and diplomacy around the world and
it revealed some frankly horrifying
stuff never before released death toll
numbers that were much higher than
previously thought and really disturbing
footage of American soldiers killing
Iraqi civilians including children and
journalists the Pentagon was furious at
these leaks and the public was kind of
torn on whether Julian Assange was a
heroic journalist or an anti-American
villain in the next chapter of his life
would be spent trying to avoid arrest by
the US government the next part of this
series finds Assange at the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London